the only reason my hair makeup is done
like this is because a hair person and a
makeup person got paid to make my hair
makeup like this for a different project
earlier today I recycle it's prom season
and you can't spell prom
without arm which is the general feeling
I have around from my prom wasn't
exceptional it was accepted by me I was
fine it was totally fine I wore a black
sparkly halter dress from the Deb you
know it or you don't I got my hair done
at the JC Penney salon I got my makeup
done at the Macy's makeup counter live
in that middle-class suburban life I
went to prom with a guy from a track
team and we danced and then we went home
that's literally what happened
regardless its prom season and so I
decided to give you some prom look
inspiration there are five different
last-minute prom looks inspired by five
different personality types
take a look here's our sporty look yeah
you are wearing sweat pants but you know
what they're sparkle sweat pants and is
that an open toed shoe you know it is
it's formal and yes your hair is in a
ponytail but you had your aunt curl the
ends of it because you're a princess and
yeah you're wearing a plain white
t-shirt but you're not wearing a sports
bra you're wearing a real bra because
it's prom you might be trying to look
less sweaty than you normally do but
you're not trying to pretend you know
how to dance what you do know is how to
play basketball let's get back to the
court this is our basic look you're the
girl that wears the things you see in
the magazines and the things that you
see on television and you think that it
makes you special
until you realize someone else also
thinks they're special and when you see
someone else that thinks they're special
like you're special it ruins your
special your special the magazines and
the
a vision told you that you're special in
what happens when you're not special
you're nothing cute manicure this next
look is our artist look you know that
you're better than everyone because you
see the world differently you see the
world through the eyes of your mom
storage ottoman and through the shoes of
some dirty towels that's your problem
look and you know what you dance like
everyone is watching because you're
wearing a storage Ottoman on your head
because you think it's art this next
look is our nerd look you're not at prom
you are working on your college
applications or some other sort of brain
stimulating hobby activity exercise you
hate everyone that you go to school with
and you can't wait to cure cancer
this last look is the rebel badass look
you hate everyone you go to school with
you do nothing you're told and you wear
ffensive deal with it society but then
you realize that you're at prom you
don't have to be but you want to be
because you want everyone deep down to
know you're a human dealing with life
and the hardships of it just like that
except it's harder for you well there
you go there were five different problem
looks four or five different high school
personality types I hope that this
inspired you to give notes about prom or
give all the shoes it's just a thing
it's not the most important things not
the least important thing it's just a
thing so you get as excited as you want
to about it problem didn't make me or
break me
and I personally think you don't want
your prom to make or break you because
if your prom makes you the rest of your
life is gonna be real sad and if your
prom breaks you the rest of your life is
gonna be real sad let from just be a
thing that you go to I don't know don't
forget that this Friday on e 10:30 the
grace Helbig show episode 3 we have
Miranda sings and Jim Parsons if this
isn't the
finition of TV meets internet i don't
know what is Jim Parsons from Big Bang
Theory and Miranda sings international
songstress extraordinaire I am so
excited for this episode 10:30 p.m.
following the soup on E also speaking of
great programming 3 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
this Friday same day on E is a little
show movie film I don't know what the
right phrases for it there's a piece
called side effects happening on E it is
a movie that I had a chance to be a part
of through awesomenesstv a few months
ago it involves singing dancing and
great people so 3:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time this Friday on e check it
out
or don't